hey guys hey guys what's up guys so we
are here on the set of all night and we
are about to play would you rather
welcome to would you rather accidentally
sex your sibling things a man should
never see things I can't unsee ever I'm
not you you rather give up your best
friend to date your ultimate crush oh
you think that's funny funny boy come at
me bro would you rather be the most
extra person in school well I already
was respect
would you rather accidentally send a
screenshot of a conversation to the
person you're having a conversation with
my right to say today is not my day
accidentally share a snap to your story
when you meant to send it to a friend
this isn't good this is not good okay I
have to redo high school all over again
you like yes cuz now I'll all the
lessons I've learned I'd be like hello
your boys have arrived
now show us the last picture you took
yeah what was his last picture always
feel hungry even after he that would
suck no I need to eat impressively sad
amount of pizza I'm doing reading
actually no but it's I'm gonna say yours
though because I'm tomorrow I wake up
into the ground right I'm like damn for
like a month
pictures picture thank you so much for
watching us play would you rather if you
want to see all night you can check it
out streaming exclusively on 100 I'm
saying words to do it smells like movies
[Music]